last night I was lucky enough to
encounter a secret area and blood form
and I'm going to show you how I got
there
first make sure you kill the blood star
feast and then travel back to the
hunter's dream here I talked to Garmin
and listen to his story okay after that
make your way back to the cathedral ward
the double doors here to the right that
were not previously open should now be
open take the lift up and kill this
crazy old man in a wheelchair with
Gatling gun of course
open the chest in the room to get a rune
and then proceed forward run across the
walkway make a right and jump down here
proceed along the walkway until you get
to a room filled with wooden planks
here I travel down a few planes and then
I notice that there's a door along the
wall in order to get to the door you'll
have to run and jump off this platform
to perform the run and jump hold circle
and we want to jump hit circle again
once you've made it onto the platform
open the doors before we head on up
here's your chance to turn off the video
to prevent spoilers of the secret area
here you can see the secret area
revealed as the abandoned workshop the
area looks just like the hunter's dream
open the chest and get the doll Armour
set we'll have some fun with this later
but for now proceed up the hill and grab
the hunter's bone the hunter's bone is a
consumable item that increases the
speeds of your rolling and quick steps
for the cost of six quick silver bullets
the item is unlimited use but requires
level 15 arcane now in the room where
gurmann usually is you'll pick up one of
the third of the umbilical cord in
addition you'll pick up a small hair
ornament travel back to the hunter's
dream and talk to the doll you'll now
have the ability to give the doll to
heroine if you do you'll get to see the
doll express some emotions for the first
time
like remember I feel your names
something I never felt before
what's happening to me ah
tell me hunter could this be joy the
doll will then give you a tear stone
which can be used to give you a health
point regeneration gem there can only be
one doll in the hunter's dream and
that's me for more coverage of
blood-borne stay tuned to games.com
you